- HEY, JADINKALAGE?
- YEAH, L'CARPETRON?
- CHECK OUT LEOZ.
I WONDER WHAT
HE'S DREAMING ABOUT?
- HE IS PROBABLY DREAMING
TO THE TEAM FROM THE WEST.
- I WONDER.
♪ - T'VARIUSNESS T-KING
FOR SHORT ♪
♪ I'M A BAD MAMMA-JAMMA
AND AN AWFUL SPORT ♪
-
♪ SMOOCHIE-WALLACE
YOU CAN CALL ME TYROIL ♪
♪ RAPPIN' UP RUSHES
LIKE ALUMINUM FOIL ♪
-
♪ MCCRINGLEBERRY I'M
VERY SCARY ♪
♪ IF I GOT THE BALL ♪
- L'CARPETRON DOOKMARRIOT ♪
♪ YOU BEST BE WARY
♪ I LOVE THE BALL SO MUCH ♪
♪ I WANNA MARRY IT
'CAUSE THE EASTERN SCHOOL'S ♪
♪ GONNA BEAT THE FOOLS
FROM THE WEST ♪
- OH, YEAH.
♪ WHERE FOOTBALL'S
CONCERNED WE GONNA SHOW YOU ♪
♪- WE ARE THE BEST ♪ST
-
♪ I'M IBRAHIM MOIZOOS
AND MY RHYMES ♪
♪ ARE CLEAN LIKE MY NAME
IS DR. SEUSS ♪
♪ - PROBINCRUZ III
THEY CALL ME "THE PROBE" ♪
♪ I CAN INTERCEPT BALLS
WITH MY EARLOBE ♪
♪ - SHOWER-HANDEL
THAT'S MY NAME POWER CANDLE ♪
♪ SOU- WITH JACKMERIUS ♪
- AND JAVARISON-LAMAR ♪
♪ - D'SQUARIUS
♪AND D'MARCUS PLAYS GUITAR ♪
all:
♪ 'CAUSE THE EASTERN SCHOOL'S
GONNA BEAT THE FOOLS ♪
♪ FROM THE WEST - ♪
♪ OKAY DON'T YOU KNOW
WHERE FOOTBALL'S CONCERNED ♪
♪ WE GONNA SHOW YOU
THAT WE ARE THE BEST ♪
♪ - INDEEDY, WE ARE THE BEST ♪
- [gasps]
IT MUST HAVE BEEN
ALL A DREAM.
[gasps]
OR WAS IT?
- OH, IT'S ON.
♪ - WHAT'S UP,
Y'ALL IT'S JEFFERSPIN ♪
♪ I'M THE BIG LEFT TACKLE
GONNA HELP US WIN ♪
I'LL USE MY FORCE ♪
♪ - X-WING AT ALYSSIUSNESS
- ALGERNON-SPLATTER'S ♪
♪ TO GIVE THE EAST DISTRESS
♪ WHERE IT'S AT RUNNING
THROUGH DEFENDERS ♪
♪ - Y'ALL KNOW ME ♪ATS
♪ I'M WASHINGBEARD CATCH
SO MANY BALLS ♪
♪ IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD ♪
♪ 'CAUSE YOU KNOW WE GONNA
WIN AGAINST THE EAST ♪
♪ - LISTEN WHAT WE SAID all:
WE GONNA GET THE MOST POINTS ♪
♪ - JUST TRYIN' TO CALM ♪LEAST
♪ THE VOICES
RUNNING THROUGH MY HEAD ♪
♪ - BACK IT UP
IT'S HARDUNKACHUD ♪
♪ I HIT THE Q.B. AND MAKE
A NOISE LIKE THUD ♪
♪ - CAN'T BLOCK ME
AND ALL OF THAT JAZZ ♪
♪ 'CAUSE Y'ALL DON'T WANT NONE
OF THIS OZAMATAZZ ♪
♪ - THE PLAYER... - TJ AJ
- FORMERLY KNOWN... ♪
- [screeches]
[construction noises]
♪ - LOUITH - AS MOUSECOP
- AND DONKEY TEETH - ♪
♪ I'M THE TOUCHDOWN MAN
THAT'S GRUNDLEPLINTH ♪
♪ BUT Y'ALL AIN'T READY
FOR MY MAN DAN SMITH ♪
♪ - YO YO SMITH COMMA DANIEL
OTHER KICKERS IN THE LEAGUE ♪
♪ DON'T HOLD
A CANDLE CHEERLEADERS ♪
♪ UP ON
MY CHOCOLATE CROTCH ♪
♪ THOSE GODDAMN
BABY COCKER SPANIEL ♪
'CAUSE THE BITCHES ♪MAD
SWISHER SWEETS ♪
♪ WANNA GET WITH ME GOT
ON NO OTHER TEAM CAN TOUCH ♪'
♪ THESE HITTIN' FIELD GOALS
BLUNTED BEEN DRUNK ♪
♪ WHEN I PUNTED BEEN
LIKE A HUNDRED TIMES ♪
♪ THAT I ALREADY DONE IT OH, ♪
♪ [bleep] SEE
THESE HATERS THOUGHT ♪
♪ I WAS PLAYIN' STAYIN' AWAY
FROM MY FACES ♪
♪ WITH ALL THE BULL[bleep] ♪ ♪
WHO YOU TAUNTIN'JUST REMER
WHEN YOU TOSSIN' THOSE GAUNTLETS
I'M DAN SMITH AND THE WEST IS
GETTIN' ROWDY LIKE MONSTERS
[all cheer]